anytime we interview someone they
naturally go right away to their imdb
for better or worse and they they want
to vet the person
so you have i believe six screenwriting
credits okay
can you talk about how many you've
written and how screenwriting
actually works and how selling them
actually works so you have six there
but probably you have many more that
just aren't
on your imdb yeah um that's a good
question is
i mean there's i've probably written i
don't know maybe 80 screenplays
um probably optioned or been hired to
write
at least 20 or 25 i don't even know
anymore but um the thing is that
there's different things too it's like
sometimes you can be hired to write it
write a script you know we wrote a
script for antoine fuqua who hired us to
write this movie about the lapd
so sometimes you're hired those don't
get made and then you don't they don't
show up on you know your imdb
credits or you get hired to write a
pilot i've
written several pilots for tv shows that
haven't been made too
um you know and then sometimes things
are optioned
you know or people buy things they don't
get made so it's always
different but you know um so that's
probably the
you know i don't know there's been a lot
the thing is i have this rule of thumb
to make a living
in the film business i have to have
almost 20 projects
in development or i'm working on at any
given time
so whether i'm writing something right
now or have something out there
or producing something or trying to put
something together or something over
here
because the formula i think is if i have
22 of them might get put together
so that's what i'm get paid off of so
you know because this is how i pay the
bills i have to think like that
and have to have a lot of things going
on but yeah you know that there's a lot
of things
a lot of work you do that doesn't show
up on imdb because it's
things that you wrote it didn't get made
or optioned or you know you got hired to
write
and once you get hired to write
something if it doesn't get made you
don't own the script
they own it so i don't know what they're
doing with you know several projects you
know we wrote a
really big teenage zombie thing for
qed and they're not even around anymore
so i don't know who even owns the rights
that but we got paid so someone owns it
you know so there's there's things that
happen like that
so imdb is not a full it doesn't i'm
nothing against imdb but it doesn't
indic
it's not a full barometer or it's not
your resume no
no exactly like i put my resume on
linkedin like like
i've been hired to write or you know
work on
like i don't know at least 20 things
like you know we just had a tv project
that didn't work with a really big
a-list
you know director but we got paid to
write a pilot off of that you know they
had a tv show we sold the abc that
almost got made
so you know there's a lot of things that
you know you get paid you work on but
you build those relationships too with
those people
so do you think most writers want to
take shortcuts
no i don't think so i think i don't
think it's shortcuts but i think they
just
don't dig in and do the work you know
writing a script
you know a first draft and just going
here you go world you know it's like you
may have to rewrite it over and over
especially when you haven't
done it often you know you have to learn
how things work and you have to get good
at it's like any other kind of like
craft or anything else you know it's
like you don't become great in two
months
you know you don't you can't ride a bike
amazing in two months or skateboard or
do karate in two months why do you think
you can just write a screenplay and the
world's gonna come looking for it
you have to get really good at it and
you have to learn
every day and really watch a lot of
people you have to love films too
you have to really be into films and
what's the structure of films and what
are they trying to say in
scenes and and you know just really be
passionate about it so that's that's my
thing is i don't think they take
shortcuts but they just don't do the
work
so maybe that's a gigantic shortcut but
you've got to get good at your crap
you've got to keep doing keep rewriting
right if you want to be a professional
right you should
have a ton of scripts you know
especially if you're young keep writing
a bunch of things
you'll get everyone's gonna get better
you know most professional writers are
like on their seventh or eighth script
by the time they sell something
you know so they've gotten better each
step of the way and they've taken five
or six years to get good at it
you were in a band correct yeah and what
did you play
i played guitar oh okay okay great and
how long did it take you to pick up
different chords and
feel like you could be in front of an
audience oh
the cool thing with the hair yeah that
was so
long ago i mean yeah i don't i don't
know i started playing guitar i was
13 or 14 so it was but i played a band
called hate department back then
which still are kind of around and we're
pretty successful and great guy and
they're still friends of mine which is
even more amazing all those years later
we're still all good friends
so yeah it was fun it was you know
i thought i was gonna be a rock star but
instead i ended up being a screenwriter
but you know
so it's not not the worst thing in the
world is there are there similarities
so you you needed maybe you didn't have
to go to school
for you didn't go to gti or you didn't
go to whatever juilliard but you
you learned different chords you
probably listened and mimicked different
songs
yeah a lot of similarities it's funny
you say that because it's about i think
about the rhythm of like things
like you understand rhythm in in story
and just you know same thing with with
music it's like you go here you do that
you go here you
do that because you know we talked about
i talked with a lot of people about like
films you know kind of more popular type
films not the avant-garde kind films or
like pop songs you know they're not that
complicated it's three-act structure
it's all
you know they're you hit certain beats
there's this point where
there's heartbreak all hope is lost it's
like a pop song it's very structured
you know it's not like a prog rock thing
you know there's movies like that
but those are few and far between and
not the ones that everybody sees but
for the most part films are very
structured and they
they have a rhythm and you know you know
something bad is going to happen here
when you're watching you kind of know
you know you know the pacing of a movie
they're they're all you know you know at
the end
if something happens weird at the end
you're like that can't be the end
because you know you've seen it so many
times in films
and just as music producers know this is
going to be a hit
it fits these different things the same
with film
yeah i mean not so much a hit but you
know if it's going to work or not
you know get to some but you know
there's things like like i said there's
been a few screenplays we've had out
there well i'm like wow people really
like this they've really responded to it
more than i even thought
so you never know how do you know
they leave comments or yeah they respond
you mean to the screenplays or yeah yeah
right because you just get yeah
no because you just get uh up for jobs
you know they bring you in for other
stuff or they make an offer to buy it
you know or
so so you know that's yeah if it gets
you other work
it's doing something and gets you a lot
of meetings you write a great screenplay
you have an agent send it out
you can end up with like meetings all
day long
with everybody is that its own sort of
busy work though where
you you're taking so many meetings but
then you're not actually getting the
work done or it's not a bad thing
uh it's building relationships which
paid off in the end
you